is this one of those movies based on a
true story that I watch I walk out of I
feel informed in the sense that I can go
okay so the world's that corrupt and
twisted okay cool that's a no what I'm
dealing with your hand so let's review
[Music]
dark waters so plural not to be mistaken
for dark water the singular just a
completely different movie so dark
waters like I said is based off of a
true story stars Mark Ruffalo he's a
corporate defense attorney this little
farmer comes to him and he was like my
cows are all dying that starts the ball
rolling because he starts investigating
it and he's like there's something in a
population being unwittingly poisoned
cover up at the corporate level it gets
bad and just the deeper the rabbit hole
goes the deeper you're like Holies like
I don't even remember the trailer
telling you the exact chemical or
product they're dealing with so I'm not
gonna tell you here that's watching I
was like wait I know that don't we still
use that yeah that's why these movies
are important no I mean I'm gonna tell
you something you already know everyone
was good in the movie let me mark
ruffalo due to his credit there was a
time I was like Mark Ruffalo is just
always gonna be that guy in those
romantic comedies what do I know dude is
a great actor dude I would say carries
this movie but Anne Hathaway who plays
his wife in the movie she was really
good too bringing on the jokes about
Hulk and Catwoman being married but she
was great too and and that whole thing
works because when someone so dives into
something like this and takes on this
thing I would say projects that's just a
project it's a life quest at this point
it's what it becomes for this guy and it
takes years it really consumes his life
so you see how that affects the home how
his wife's dealing with it it's a very
important thing to see that kind of
stress because you know people take
things on and movies like yeah but
what's their marriage okay even have Tim
Robbins Bill Pullman they're good too
and you know I I just enjoy these
investigative style movies this movie
really did remind me of spotlight I feel
like every review is gonna be like an
spotlight but it does remind me of
spotlight where you're getting the data
and you're just going along this ride
and you're like holy finish it's it
really is a story of a guy who just took
on these corporate overlords because
check this out this is crazy I know but
coming close it was the right thing to
do we'd all like to think we would do
that but really if you really think
about it if you think of the strain it
will put on your home life if you're
looking down the barrel of that
corporate shotgun but you really do it
it's it's tough and it's the great thing
about this guy dude is a real guy he
real
did this I gotta give credit to the
research that had to have gone on in
order to make this movie you can't just
whip this movie out you can't just feel
like I read a Wikipedia article once or
I feel like I'm informed ish let's make
this movie pointing these fingers so a
lot of research had to have happened in
order for this movie to happen so props
on that - it's about corporate cover-up
Seth
birth defects covered this one guy who's
like I'm gonna shine the light on it and
you're not really prepared how many
years it's gonna timey third jumps in
this movie that are many years and for
the first half maybe two thirds of this
movie it's actually remarkably smooth
including these jumps the last act felt
like this movie could have been another
hour hour and a half long and they were
like we're not gonna
we can't overclock it like that all
right let's get to the end so feels like
it's just kind of like alright sped to
the end of the movie but looking at it
pacing wise I feel like that was the
right thing to do that was a good call
it was in this weird state of downtime
in terms of the investigation so like
what we're gonna do just hang around in
the downtime really the story you're
watching is it's something that you
might walk out of this movie having this
[ __ ] scare daddy but this movie was well
acted it was interesting it was
intriguing you're along for the
investigative ride it's a strong look as
to how corporations regardless of
fallout casualties or anything will hide
information to save their own ass
nothing new there I know but still I
suppose one of the reasons I compared
this movie to spotlight it's not only
because the investigative aspect but
it's based on a true story and the
people who were affected the victims are
still here where the families are and
their victims - so it's you got to tread
lightly and very carefully you got to do
it all justice with respect and I
thought they really did I'm glad this
movie shines a light on it because
people need to know about this as much
as I'm using the past tense in this
video and as much as this movie showed
us what got the ball rolling the fight
that they're trying to fight is still
happening which makes it crazier it's
like why haven't I heard more about this
it just seems more newsworthy than that
picture the fact that it's based on a
true story and affects us all in a
larger way than one might have thought
before they watch this movie that
elevates it to something that's gonna be
on your mind for a little bit after you
watch this what do you think movies like
this I don't usually go back to and
watch but regardless I'm gonna say dark
waters it's worth watching and worth
buying on blu-ray
alright so dark waters have you seen it
what do you think about it or what's
your favorite investigative movie based
on a true story a movie about digging
through the
ruble of information finding the
unsettling facts Lex your favorite
whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]